SO, A SUBJECT CLOSE TO MY HEART.
>> IN THE CITY I AM IN, WE SEE
SO MANY PEOPLE MOVING THROUGH.
HERE'S NEW VIDEO THAT SHOWS
UKRAINIANS FLEEING INCITY.
ONE HOO WHO FLED EIS MAREOY ELY
EBEING FORCE SAID HIS HIM AS HE
LECOVERED FROM THE HIS INJURY A
IN LVIV.
>> CAN YOU TELL ME WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> WE SITE IN CAR.
AND I REMEMBER I LOOK AT MY
BROKEN WATCH AND I WILL NOT
LOOK.
WE GO TO BED E.
I GO TO BED.
I SEE SOMETHING GLASS OR
SOMETHING.
ONE SECOND AND I SEE A YELLOW
EXPLOSION SOUNGT YEARS.
AND I JUST REMEMBER I WOKE UP
AND WROTE E.
THAT'S EVERY DAY.
AND I SEE MY MOTHER GO ON FIRE.
MY MOTHER WAS [ INAUDIBLE ]
>> YOUR MOTHER WAS STILL ALIVE
WHILE SHE WAS ON FIRE?
>> Translator: I STARTED
CRAWLING RIGHT FROM BIRTH AND
THE SHAW IN MY LARS CLOEVICAL.
I FEEL BLOOD IN MY LEFT EAR.
I HEAR SHOOTING, NOT FROM
WEAPONS OR ROCKETS OR SOMETHING.
AND I CLING TO STAIRS AND HIDE.
I SCREAMING ONE TIME.
TWO MINUTES AND THREE.
I AND I WOULD BE IN SOCKS.
>> CAN'T WALK.
>> EXPLOSION.
AND THESE PEOPLE TAKE A OFF TO
HIS HOUSE.
>> WRAPPED IN BLANKETS?
>> AND YOUR MOTHER DURING THIS?
>> SHE DIED AT THE LOCATION AND
SHE WAS STILL ALIVE WHEN SHE
BOUGHT THE LIAR AND SHE JUZ
BURNED.
>> AND WHEN DOCTORS AT HOSPITAL,
I'M LOOKING FO FOR POLICE OR
FIND MY FATHER.
>> YOU AND YOUR FATHER, ARE YOU
OKAY?
>> FATHER IS.
YOU UNDERSTAND.
YOUR WIFE IS DEAD AND YOU'RE
LOOKING TO YOUR SON.
I THINK [ INAUDIBLE ]
>> AND MYSELF, I THINK I HAVEN'T
REALIZED EVERYTHING TO THE FULL
EXTENT.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT THE WORLD TO
KNOW ABOUT YOUR
MOTHER?
>> SORRY.
>> I'M SORRY.
EXCUSE ME.
>> Translator: MY MOTHER WAS A
VERY BEAUTIFUL WOMAN.
SHE WAS LIKES TO BE TIDY AND
CLEAN.
AND WE SUPPORTED HER.
BUT NOW IT IS VERY DIFFICULT
WITHOUT MOM.
>> SHE HAS A BEAUTIFUL AND BRAVE
SON.
AND I'M SO SORRY YOU'VE GONE
THROUGH THIS.
DO YOU THINK YOU'LL GET BACK TO
CHERNIHIV?
>> WILL I BACK TO CHERNIHIV?
>> YES.
>> BACK TO MY CITY AND I WANT TO
REBUILD MY CITY BECAUSE IT IS
MY -- IT IS MY CITY.
I -- ALL MY LIFE I LIVE IN THIS.
IT IS VERY HARD TO LOOK WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH MY CITY.
>> WHAT WILL YOU DO NOW?
>> NOW I JUST -- JUST I WANT
TO --
>> Translator: I WANT TO
DISTANCE MYSELF FROM THIS A
LITTLE BIT.
>> I JUST WANT TO -- MAYBE I
CAN'T EXPLAIN FOR YOU BECAUSE --
>> I UNDERSTAND.
YOU WANT TO GET AWAY FROM THIS,
AT LEAST SOMEHOW IF YOU CAN,
PLAY MUSIC, BE A 15-YEAR-OLD
KID.
CAN YOU PLAY RIGHT NOW?
CAN YOU PLAY THE GUITAR?
>> IT'S SONG, OUR GROUP, SONG
CALLED "NIGHT."
♪♪
>> IT IS NICE TO SEE YOU SMILE.
>> LOOK, I HOPE YOU LIVE A LONG
AND MEANINGFUL LIFE.
AND I'M GLAD YOU MADE IT THROUGH
THIS.
I'M SO SORRY FOR WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN THROUGH.
THANK YOU.
>> WHAT A SPECIAL REPORT,
BERMAN.
>> HE'S THE SAME AGE AS MY SONS.
AND TO SEE WHAT HE'S BEEN
THROUGH, IT'S JUST HEART
BREAKING TO SEE THAT, AND YOU
CAN SEE HOW HURT HE IS,
OBVIOUSLY THE LOSS OF HIS
MOTHER,  OBVIOUSLY TAKING CARE
IN SOME WAYS EMOTIONALLY OF HIS
FATHER, BUT JUST COMING TO GRIPS
WITH WHAT'S HAPPENED TO HIS HOME
AND HIS COUNTRY, YOU CAN SEE H